A bright flash of light awakes Pietro Wilson from
his vegetative state. He sits up and brushes the
sand off himself, looking around the desolate
desert he’s found himself in. How did he get here?
The last thing he remembers is uncovering secret
orders from the leaders of the SCP Foundation,
just before they declared war on humanity.
Unfortunately, the most important parts of the
files had been redacted. Now he's on a mission to
finally discover why the SCP Foundation is trying
to kill every last human on the planet... but
there is something else he has to deal with first.
“What happened?” Pietro says out loud as he looks
at his vitals in the heads up display of SCP-5000.
He is still contained within the exclusionary
suit that makes him undetectable to human senses.
He checks the date and gasps in surprise. “Three
months! I’ve been passed out for three months!”
He stands up and looks across the
barren landscape. The screen inside
the suit indicates he has traversed half of the
country since he left Site-19 three months ago.
Pietro looks down at one of his hands. He is
holding a black leather briefcase. “Where did
that come from?” he wonders. Pietro has
no idea what is inside the briefcase,
but he knows it definitely isn’t
round. He tries to let it go,
his fingers won’t open. He uses his other hand
to try and pry the briefcase away from himself,
but his hand only clasps to it harder. Then a wave
of calm washes over him. Something inside his head
speaks to him, but it’s not a voice, more like a
feeling. It is a sense of purpose, and Pietro’s
new mission in life is to deliver this briefcase
to SCP-579, nothing else is as important.
Pietro Wilson takes a deep breath and embraces his
new purpose in life. He still wants to uncover the
reason that the SCP Foundation is trying to wipe
out humanity, but this will have to wait until
he delivers the briefcase to SCP-579. Pietro
does not know exactly where 579 is located, but
he can feel a pull in a certain direction, so he
begins to walk. Pietro brings up the information
stored in the SCP-5000 suit from the Foundation’s
database. He finds that all information about what
SCP-579 is has been expunged from the record.
The only useful information in the file is that
the Keter level SCP is located at Site-62c.
At least Pietro has a destination to aim for.
He travels for days without seeing a living
soul. But he does pass thousands of corpses.
He tries to ignore them but one stands out to
him inside a house as he searches for supplies.
It's the body of a recently deceased boy. He
couldn't have been more than eight years old.
He was so young, Pietro thinks. He bends over
to scoop up the body and bury it outside. As
his hand touches the body, the boy’s skin begins
to move. It is as if hundreds of tiny creatures
are scurrying just under the skin. Then, from out
of every orifice, comes hundreds of little pale
worms. each with the face of the boy. They are
all cackling as they crawl off the boy’s body and
into a drain a few feet away. Pietro jumps back
and runs. That is the last person I try to bury,
he thinks. Pietro pushes forward, the hundreds
of little laughing worms haunting his thoughts,
until he puts a significant distance
between himself and the little boy’s body.
Pietro continues to walk towards the direction of
Site-62c. He passes more corpses, but decides to
stay clear of them. Although the suit makes it
so Pietro doesn’t need to rest, he can only go
so fast. He enters a small abandoned town that
looks like something out of an old western movie.
A tumbleweed blows across the dirt road. Pietro
sits on the wooden step of the local saloon and
takes a break. He looks down at the briefcase
in his hand. He hasn’t had the urge to open it,
only to deliver it to SCP-579. Pietro puts the
black briefcase on his lap. He stares at it and
slides his hands along the leather, stops with his
thumb on the latch, and pushes. The silver locks
snap open. Pietro opens the briefcase... a
bright light beams out, and he passes out.
When Pietro comes to again he is miles closer to
Site-62c. There is a warm feeling enveloping his
body. He looks down at the briefcase which is now
closed. Wow, this thing is like my own personal
skip button, Pietro thinks. He holds up the
briefcase, unlatches the locks, sees the bright
light, and passes out again. He awakes once again
miles away from his last position. So it wasn’t
just a one-off effect. Pietro continues walking
across the country, switching between using his
own legs and whatever magic is contained within
the briefcase. He is making faster progress now.
As he walks through a dense deciduous forest he
comes across a pack of wolves eating the remains
of an SCP Agent. Pietro is undetectable
to the wolves thanks to the SCP-5000 suit
and he makes his way over to the pack, quietly
grabbing a laptop laying on the ground next to
the agent’s body. Pietro takes the laptop and goes
a way deeper into the forest before stopping to
boot up the computer. He has not forgotten about
the horrors the SCP Foundation has released and
he needs to know how the world has been doing over
the last few months. What he finds is... not good.
The SCP Foundation has triggered the eruption of
Yellowstone destroying SCP-2000, which unknown to
Pietro, contained the failsafe for rebuilding
human society in the event of a world ending
scenario, which this was starting to look more and
more like. It was only a matter of time now before
the soot and ash thrown up by the eruption blocks
out the sun in much of what is left of the United
States. The Foundation has also found a way to get
SCP-2241 to do their dirty work at refugee camps.
The young brown haired boy is most likely being
manipulated by the Foundation under the pretenses
that they are only doing what’s best for “their”
child. He has caused whole groups of refugees to
turn on eachother, leading to a massacre.
The last entry says that the young boy is
being sent to the The Global Occult Coalition
hold out at Ganzir, to help destroy some of the
last threats to the SCP Foundation. A series of
other SCPs have been dispatched by the Foundation
around the world to continue the destruction
of humanity. They even managed to use temporal
anomalies to make it Christmas time everywhere
around the world so SCP-4666, the brutal Yule-tide
creature that stalks the homes of children, is
free to cause chaos. Pietro had seen enough.
He slams the laptop shut, throws it against the
trunk of a tree., and opens the briefcase again.
He awakes standing feet away from a group
of Global Occult Coalition soldiers who are
sitting around a campfire. Maybe they know why
the SCP Foundation is trying to end the world,
he thinks. He decides that it is too
risky to show himself to the soldiers,
but takes some solace in sitting around the
campfire with other living humans. The soldiers
are sharing stories about what is happening,
one catches the attention of Pietro Wilson.
It is strange, but also may hold a clue as to why
the SCP Foundation is trying to wipe out humanity.
One of the soldiers recounts an event that
he witnessed before leaving the Global Occult
Coalition’s headquarters at Ganzir. They had just
captured an SCP soldier trying to break into the
base. The infiltrator's name was Samuel Ross.
He had been strapped into an interrogation chair
and questioned. The interviewers were not getting
anywhere until Ross was threatened with torture,
to which he responded “Do what you want. Once
you realize you're not supposed to feel pain,
there's nothing to be afraid of anymore.”
Pietro sits up straight and
starts to listen more intently.
He remembers stumbling across SCP soldiers on
his way to Site-19 that exhibited the same “no
pain” mentality that this
Samuel Ross seems to have.
After that odd statement by Samuel Ross there
was the sound of wind. It started slow at first,
then ramped up until it was howling like a
hurricane. That’s when the screaming started.
The screams became louder and climbed to
a higher pitch. Then the room went dead
silent. The last thing that Samuel Ross said
was, “I really liked you guys, so I was trying
to be nice. We're so kind to you, you know. We
fight in the light so you can die in the dark.”
Pietro sits back on his haunches and rocks back
and forth. He has an ominous feeling that there
is a connection between the missing pain of the
SCP soldiers, and the reason why the Foundation
declared war on humanity. The soldier who
told the story of Samual Ross stands up.
“After that interview is when the destruction
of Ganzir started from the inside. It is why
the Global Occult Coalition is no more. God help
us all.” The soldier, finished with his story,
turns from the others and starts to walk away.
As the soldier makes his way towards the woods
Pietro can just barely make out that he’s taken
his pistol from its holster before he disappears
into the darkness. The world truly has gone
mad. Pietro opens the briefcase and blacks out.
Pietro sluggishly continues his walk. He’s
moving down a rocky path in the middle of the
forest and his will to keep going is slowly being
drained. The only reason he has not sat down and
given up is because of the driving urge to get the
briefcase to 579. He wants so badly to concentrate
and discover the reason that the Foundation
released the SCPs on humanity, but the need
to reach 579 won’t let him to focus on anything
else. He’s noticed though that every time he
opens the briefcase to skip ahead, he makes less
and less progress. The warm feeling of the first
few transports has been replaced by a nauseated
headache every time he comes out of the trance.
Pietro exits the forest into an open field. The
wind blows across the high grass looking like
green waves, and standing scattered throughout
the field are statues. As Pietro approaches,
he sees that they are statues of Mobile Task Force
Foundation soldiers. He slowly walks closer to the
white marble statues. He reaches the first one and
looks at the face of the frozen soldier, his eyes
have been scooped out, all that remains are black,
empty, sockets. The arms of the soldier have been
carved into blades, like a praying mantis. He
walks past the first statue and proceeds to the
next one when he hears something move in the grass
behind him. He spins around to look at the statue.
He could have swore it was in a slightly different
position. No, that’s crazy, Pietro thinks.
He continues to the next statue. It
is another carving of a MTF soldier,
no eyes, blades for arms. “This is really creepy,”
Pietro says aloud. He proceeds through the field.
He walks up a slight hill and turns
around to look at the field of statues.
What he sees is terrifying. The statues have
all moved and are now in different positions.
It appears as if they were slashing through
the area looking for something… or someone.
Pietro continues over the hill and comes upon
a group of refugees. They are picking through
the field looking for food to eat. A fog
begins to move in, it is being swept across
the meadow by the wind. Pietro watches from a
distance as the fog envelopes the small group.
Suddenly there is screaming and the sound of
blades going through flesh. The screams cease
almost immediately. Pietro runs down the hill to
where the refugees were. The fog lifts. The group
of people have been cut to pieces. Standing
in the middle of the carnage is one of the
MTF soldier statues, blood dripping from its
blade arms. Pietro knows what to do… he runs.
After a few miles Pietro slows to catch his
breath. “Those statues must have been created
by the Foundation” he thinks, “It’s as if they
are frozen in place, but as soon as you take your
eyes off them they can move with killer speed.
Even in the suit my eyesight can stop them…
but they can’t see me… they must know
I’m there though since they can’t move.”
Pietro Wilson opens the briefcase one again,
for what he didn’t know would be the last time.
When he comes to this time he is near Site-62c.
He can feel himself being pulled stronger than
ever in the direction of his destination. He
walks down a deserted road past the husks of burnt
vehicles and at the end is the gate to Site-62c.
There are no guards or security of any kind. It
looks like the site has been abandoned for a long
time and the gate is wide open, beckoning Pietro
Wilson into Site-62c... where SCP-579 waits.
Pietro Wilson enters the dark hallway he somehow
knows leads down into the crypt of Site-62c.
The walls drip with what he hopes is water from
leaking pipes, but it has a metallic smell, and
is much too red to actually be water. He begins to
feel nauseous. It gets harder to breathe. Even the
SCP-5000 suit can’t keep him calm. He turns and
runs back up the stairs out of Site-62c. He stops
a few feet from the entryway, bends over, and
vomits. Pietro begins to sob uncontrollably as the
memories of everything that has happened over the
past several months suffocates his will to go on.
Then, as if an invisible force that refuses to
let him go takes control. Pietro feels as if a
gun has been shoved into the small of his
back. He is being sent back into Site-62c
whether he wants to go or not. He is unsure
if what is forcing him back into the base is
inside the briefcase, his own uncontrollable
urge to know what is going on, or SCP-579 itself,
but he cannot stop himself from re-entering
the doorway and preceding into Site-62c. He
doesn’t know what SCP-579 looks like, but Pietro
has a sinister feeling that it is watching him.
He reaches the bottom of the stairway
and proceeds down a dark hallway.
The power went out long ago and the only light
in the depths of Site-62c is the dim glow coming
from the helmet of the SCP-5000 suit. Pietro
notices long gashes along the concrete walls,
as if someone took a giant knife and dragged
it from one end of the hallway to the other.
There is something at the end of the
corridor that Pietro can’t make out.
As he gets closer the lights on
the SCP-5000 suit begin to flicker.
The thing at the end of the hallway seems to move
slightly each time the lights on the suit dim.
The lights of the suit go out completely and the
entire hallway is plunged into darkness. Only for
a second though, and when the lights come back
on a statue of a MTF soldier looms over Pietro,
its eyes are empty sockets, its
lips are turned up in a snarl,
the arms have been filed into blades. “No!”
Pietro screams. He dodges around the statue,
the moment it is out of his sight he hears the
sound of blades on concrete, as the statue of
the soldier comes to life and begins slashing
its way down the hallway. It cannot see Pietro,
but it knows he is there. It slashes all around,
trying to connect with whoever is there with it.
Pietro runs to the end of the hallway and reaches
a door. He presses against the heavy metal door
open, straining against its weight all while the
blind statue is still slashing, coming closer and
closer. The door is almost open, but then Pietro
feels a blade lacerate the back of the suit,
cutting deeply into the skin of his back, missing
his spinal cord by millimeters. Another blade
enters through the back of his shoulder piercing
straight through. He somehow pulls himself through
the cracked doorway and kicks the metal door shut
behind him. He can hear the banging and scraping
of blades outside of the metal door. The creature
has not given up and is trying to break in.
Pietro turns around to see he is in an observation
chamber full of instruments and screens.
Blood runs down his back from the wounds inflicted
by the statue. He walks slowly over to the window,
on the desk in front of him is a file
labeled SCP-579. He looks through the
observation glass and down into the chamber
below. It is too dark to make anything out,
but Pietro can feel that SCP-579 is down there
looking up at him. Pietro looks to his left and
sees a hole in the floor. He walks over and looks
down. It leads right into the containment chamber
of 579. “Let’s get this over with,” Pietro says
out loud. He holds the briefcase over the hole and
tries to open his hand. His finger won’t budge.
SCP-579 wants him to hand deliver the briefcase..
Pietro Wilson takes a deep breath, closes
his eyes, and steps into the opening of
the hole. He falls. In the moments before
he lands in SCP-579’s containment chamber
something comes to him. He realizes that he isn’t
going to be a hero, he isn’t going to figure out
why the SCP Foundation is trying to wipe out
humanity… and he isn’t going to survive. He
lands hard on the ground below. It is completely
dark, except for a shadow that moves in the
corner of the containment chamber. Pietro Wilson
creates one last log, “if anyone ever reads this,
please, please, figure out why. Explain it to me.
Someone … anyone. I don't get it. I just don't get
it…” SCP-579 steps into the glow that the SCP-5000
suit is giving off. Pietro Wilson looks up at
it. “Oh … so that's how it is.” he says before
SCP-5000 creates its final log: LIFE SIGNS LOST.
SCP-5000 appeared in a flash of light
in the containment chamber of SCP-579
located in Site-62C. The researchers monitoring
SCP-579 had no idea where the suit came from
or why it contained the body of Pietro Wilson,
a foundation employee who is assigned to Site-06
and is very much alive. Wilson appears
to have no knowledge of SCP-5000
or memories of the events logged in SCP-5000’s
databanks. Although the suit is believed to have
been capable at one point of a number
of anomalous functions and abilities,
the damage it has sustained has rendered it
inoperable except for the storage of data files,
which have now been archived and
stored on secure Foundation servers.
Now check out the earlier
episodes of Pietro Wilson
and SCP-5000 by watching SCP-5000 - The
Suit. Or watch SCP-106 - The Old Man Escape.